nearly six months to the day since war
broke out in europe and this continent
all of it is still reeling
but while the cost of war there is human
and horrific there's a cost here too and
it's also a crisis
there's a sense in the air that autumn
is coming and with it extortionate bills
energy some three times what it was
inflation could exceed 18
we'll learn the new energy price cap
later this week customers like simon a
veteran on an army pension and universal
credit can only worry and wait
potentially
we're going to spend most of the winter
just in the one room with uh
with an electric fire because that's
probably going to be cheaper than firing
up the central heating system constantly
the cap should be set at a level that is
low but they just keep on increasing it
increasing it increasing it
and
it is like when is it going to end when
is there going to be a light at the end
of the tunnel and it's no wonder he's
fearful in face of the forecasts just
look the red bars show predictions for
the prices in october then january then
april by the spring bills could exceed 5
000 pounds a year and this is why the
wholesale gas price it surged when the
invasion first came now back up to
similar levels and still rising
part of the explanation lies here the
pipes that carry russian gas to europe
the nordstream pipeline will be shut off
for three full days next week
maintenance say the russians a threat in
the eyes of the market what we've seen
beyond any doubt over recent months is a
full weaponization of russian gas supply
to europe uh the main objective is to
try and stymie any effort to rebuild
stocks ahead of this winter so that
during this winter we are
uh reliant on russian gas we really are
stuck with very high prices for at least
a couple of years
really out to the middle of the decade
and it is energy that will drive
skyrocketing inflation intervention
could prevent the most dire predictions
but it will be complex
the problem with a high gas price is
that its impact goes far beyond the cost
of just heating our homes it touches
everything from the fertilizer needed to
grow our food to factories that produce
our essential goods and while there
isn't much the government can do to
bring down the price there are things it
could do to mitigate the impact the
pressure here is really mounting
most now agree the help on offer from
the leadership contenders will not be
enough and an impoverished population
could hasten the forecasted recession
making everything worse it is an
exceedingly bleak picture and a deeply
worrying time helen and smith sky news